hat kein Zuhause mehr nach 66 Jahren in
der Emiliano zapata-straße 68 ist sie
rausgeflogen nicht weil sie die Miete
nicht bezahlt hat oder eine schlechte
Mieterin war sondern weil der Besitzer
des Gebäude sanieren und die Bewohner
loswerden wollte zuerst versuchte er es
mit Drohungen am Ende kam die
Zwangsräumung
dieses Gebäude ist meine ganze Welt hier
war ich als Kind glücklich die habe ich
meinen Mann kennengelernt habe
geheiratet hatte meine Kinder hier habe
ich alles erlebt
rofine und ihre Töchter retteten sich
und ihren Besitz unter eine Plane auf
dem Gehsteig seit zwei Tagen sitzen sie
hier wissen nicht weiter zunächst einmal
werden sie wohl bei Verwandten
unterkommen
ich wollte heulen schreien aber ich kann
mir das nicht erlauben wegen meiner
Töchter wenn die sehen dass ich
deprimiert bin dann geben sie auch auf
ich muss Stärke zeigen und das alles
nach innenkehren ich weine im
Verborgenen denn wenn ich gar nicht
Weine hat der Schmerz für immer
Zwangsräumungen kommen in Mexiko City
häufig vor
mieterschutzgesetze sind schwach oft
genug ein Vorwand und Bewohner
rauszuschmeißen zwischen 2019 und 2022
stieg die Zahl um fast ein Drittel an
mitverantwortlich für die steigende
Wohnungsnot die ständig wachsende Zahl
an digitalnomaden Ausländer die an
keinen festen Arbeitsplatz gebunden sind
finden in Mexiko City mit seinen vielen
Grünflächen den guten Essen und
angenehmen Klima eine hohe
Lebensqualität die zahlungskräftigen
Nomaden erhöhen den Druck auf den
Immobilienmarkt
Rachel aus Boston lebt seit 2016 hier
sie arbeitet online für einen
amerikanischen Verlag nebenher macht sie
Kunst ihre Wohnung liegt wenige Blocks
vom Innviertel condesser entfernt
hier alles ist ich mag die Geräusche die
Leute die Energie ich komme aus Boston
wo ist die Hälfte des Jahres kalt und
dunkel ist und die Menschen sich in
ihren Häusern verstecken
Rachel weiß dass ihre Anwesenheit in der
Wahl Heimat zwei Seiten hat
wer hier herkommt kann sich mit seinem
Einkommen in der Regel viel mehr leisten
als zu Hause und das ist toll
aber es ist doch problematisch weil die
Mieten in diesen Gegenden wahnsinnig
hoch sind meine mexikanische Partnerin
könnte es sich nie leisten in diesem
Stadtteil zu wohnen und sie hat einen
Masterabschluss
manchmal lädt Rachel andere
digital-nomaden zu sich nach Hause zum
coworken ein Lauren erzählt dass sich
die Stimmung in den drei Jahren die sie
jetzt hier ist verändert hat
es ist ständig Thema in Unterhaltungen
mit mexikanischen Freunden manchmal ist
es richtig unangenehm immer dieses
pinsche Gringos die verdammten Gringos
nervige Ausländer kommen hierher und
treiben die Mieten hoch
Rachel und ihre Freunde wollen gute
Nachbarn sein bemühen sich um
Integration setzen sich in der Gemeinde
sozial ein doch Mexiko sieht die
verändert sich passt sich an die vielen
Ausländer an schicke Cafés ersetzen
immer mehr takkostände und
Straßenverkäufer
Altbauten weichen Luxuswohnungen
und Zähne Restaurants
durch gefühlte Exklusivität
ich glaube der Koch kommt aus New York
es hat nur Freitag und Samstag auf und
du bekommst die Adresse nur auf
Instagram
der messkal ist das beste hier sie haben
viele verschiedene die man probieren
kann
die Nomaden sind gut fürs Geschäft
allein 2021 trugen sie fast eine halbe
Milliarde Euro zur wirtschaftsbilanz der
Stadt bei die Bürgermeisterin fördert
den Zustrom macht einen Deal mit Airbnb
um noch mehr Ausländer anzulocken eine
Antwort auf die wachsende Wohnungsnot
bietet sie nicht
und so frisst sich die Gentrifizierung
in immer mehr stattgebietet la opera ist
traditionell ein Arbeiterviertel aber
seine Nähe zum Stadtzentrum macht es
attraktiv für Immobilien Entwicklung
auch Marlene und ihre Mutter haben ihre
Wohnung verloren unter einem Vorwand
verschaffen sich 80 Polizisten gewaltsam
Zugang zum Gebäude zerrten sie ins Freie
erst vier Monate später durften sie ihre
Sachen holen
es ist so schrecklich es tut mir so weh
dass sie uns das angetan haben ohne
Grund
in den Stadtteilen nah dem Zentrum
sprechen wir Nachbarn nur noch von der
immobilienmafia sie werfen ein Auge auf
ein Objekt und nehmen es sich
Marlene gibt die Schuld nicht den
digital-nomaden sondern der Profitgier
der Immobilienbesitzer und dem
mangelnden
[Musik]
es ist nicht die Schuld der Ausländer
sondern der Leute hier die eine
Gelegenheit sehen mehr Profit zu machen
klar andere können mehr zahlen als wir
wir haben einfach nicht die gleiche
Kaufkraft für uns ist das eine
Entscheidung zwischen höherer Miete und
Essen kaufen
der lange Arm der Gentrifizierung reicht
bis in Traditionen wie den sonntaglichen
Tanz hier im Park von Santa Maria eine
neue Bezirksverwaltung will das Viertel
aufpolieren fand die Musik zu laut und
verbot die Veranstaltungen die Anwohner
werden sich
wir kommen jeden Sonntag hierher um Spaß
zu haben es ist so eine unbändige Freude
ältere Menschen dabei zuzusehen
wir wollen diese Tradition nicht
verlieren
wir sind die Speerspitze im Kampf gegen
die Gentrifizierung
fürs erste haben sie sich das Recht
erkämpft hier weiter zu tanzen ihre
Ausgelassenheit ist ein Ausdruck dessen
was Mexiko so besonders macht und wohl
auch so attraktiv für Menschen von außen
Mexico City kämpft um seine Seele
[Musik]